You are beaten.
It is useless to resist.
Don't let yourself be destroyed as Obi-Wan did.
There is no escape.
Don't make me destroy you.
Luke, you do not yet realize your importance.
You have only begun to discover your power.
Join me and I will complete your training.
With our combined strength, we can end this destructive conflict and bring order to the galaxy.
I'll never join you!
If you only knew the power of the dark side.
Obi-Wan never told you what happened to your father.
He told me enough!
He told me you killed him.
No, I am your father.
No, no, it's not true!
That's impossible!
Search your feelings.
You know it to be true.
No! No!
Luke, you can destroy the emperor.
He has foreseen this.
It is your destiny.
Join me, and together, we can rule the galaxy as father and son.
Come with me. It is the only way.